it is a crunch week in the brexit
process
all eyes are on whether a trade deal can
be struck
both sides know it is now or never
britain's chief negotiator david frost
determined not to be distracted by the
comings and goings in downing street
but rather set on trying to get that
trade deal
next week are you staying in posts
now in brussels for talks he tweeted we
are working to get
a deal but the only one that's possible
is one that is compatible with our
sovereignty
and takes back control of our laws our
trade and our waters
that has been our consistent position
from the start
and i will not be changing it he wrote
one sticking point threatens to bring
things to a standstill
and that's the uk's insistence on a kind
of trade insurance policy
which breaks the terms of the withdrawal
agreement signed by the prime minister
back in january
i've spoken to a lot of eu capitals
about this and
also eu commissioners and i think there
is an absolutely
unanimous view that if the british
government deliberately
decides to break international law and
undermine a treaty that's not even 12
months old
well then why would the eu sign up to a
new deal um
when the uk is breaking the existing one
i hope you were listening to
good morning simon coveney interview um
he said that the eu won't do
a trade deal there's unanimous agreement
on that if the uk government tries to
restore measures to the internal market
bill which break
the law are you going to try and do that
yes we will be putting those measures
back because they are very important
they just really
bring clarity to mechanisms that are
already
in the withdrawal agreement this is all
about the internal market bill
which the government brought in they say
to ensure the trade of goods and
services
between all four home nations remain
barrier-free
after the brexit transition period ends
at the end of the year
one of the major issues is how the same
rules can apply to northern
ireland when it shares a border with the
republic of ireland
which will remain in the eu the eu says
the bill
breaks the terms of the withdrawal
agreement as well as international law
the bill ended up here at the house of
lords and pairs voted overwhelmingly to
take out the bits
that would allow ministers to break
international law
but the government is now determined to
put those bits
straight back in again and that sets the
tone
for the final stages of britain's
negotiation with europe
i think the difficult thing for the
prime minister is that any deal that is
reached with the eu
will still come with quite a lot of
disruption and so if he does
make compromises and and agree something
that still makes it much harder to trade
with the eu the prime minister will then
need to own that
whereas in a no deal scenario it's sort
of easier to blame the eu for any
disruption that's coming and i think
that's ultimately what the prime
minister is going to have to to make a
decision on
it's an impasse a stalemate the kind of
stubborn
deadlock that has defined brexit from
the very start
mick martin sky news westminster